الا بعد باريس بعد ما عملت الشهاده في
باريس عدت الى دمشق ذكرتها بالبديرس
مركزنا كثير عليها حاولت تعلم بمعهد
الفنون حيث دراسه ولكن ما تيسرت الامور
كاستاذ في الكليه فذهبت الى
الرسم تماما في كيف تعاملت معك المدينه
المشاهد المتلقي السوري كيف تتعامل مع
لوحه قديش كان قديش كان الا حضور الجيش
الحساس بيفرق يعني همم
هذه العزله يعني اعطتني شيء بالمقابل انه
همم
جمهور السوري كله احترم شغليه
وحب شغلي
هلا بتنذكر لحد الان انه 87 ان سويت معرض
شغلي خلال 15 سنه وبعته كله بصاله اورنينا
يعني كان يمكن المعرض الاول اللي كان
بينباع كلياته هاي الصادق كانت فاتحه جديد
وقتها بالصالحيه
فعندي
جمهور واسع بدمشق عندي مجموعه مقتنيين
يعني ما كنت ما كان عندي شيء
هدف واحد انه انا تعلمت لازم يفيد البلد
على سوريا
[موسيقى]
من اهم المعارض بحياتي واحد اسواق بيروت
والثاني ببلاتيني ومتور